the notorious curb nudge it's not that
hard to do it's just extremely tricky
now's the time i want to see your full
effort i want to see you get up onto
this curve
what's up everyone i hope quarantine's
not been too rough on you i just had a
kidney stone so that was like nine days
of hell but i also still have a job so i
can't really complain because this is a
really really bad time for a lot of
people simply just trying to make ends
meet it's also a really bad time for
mental health you know our sanity is so
fragile and yet it's all too easy to
lose track of what keeps us sane and
personally i think the best way to keep
yourself in check is by simply going
outside just go do something like a walk
or a bike ride or my personal favorite
one wheeling an actual activity that
requires social distancing you see
there's nothing inherently dangerous
with simply being outside it's getting
close to people or touching things
that's the actual danger as long as you
can mitigate those risks you can
actually go about in public safely i
mean it's why we're still allowed to go
to grocery stores as long as we maintain
social distancing
so in this video i'm going to try to
safely teach my friends how to do one of
the most requested one-wheel tricks out
there it's called a curb nudge and it's
when you're able to actually get your
one wheel up a curb from like the street
to the sidewalk it seems to defy physics
but it's actually very doable i'm gonna
see if i can get my friends to learn how
to do it enjoy watching what i'm sure
will be a lot of flailing and failing
the notorious curb nudge it's not that
hard to do it's just extremely tricky
because there are three things you got
to do in very rapid succession and if
you don't do them in the correct order
it just doesn't happen and the first one
is my favorite the skid stop so it's
just like extreme braking the second
thing you're gonna need to practice is
just practice getting your nose up onto
a curb without even trying to go up it
and then the last thing the foot motion
so you're jumping off of your back foot
and then your front foot here on the
curb is just sliding forward so those
are the three main things we need to
practice and then we can actually try
working on the actual nudge up let's go
ahead and get the circle here and i want
to see your guys's skid stops
[Music]
you have to fully take your foot off the
front pad or else you keep going forward
ooh and he walks away these guys
basically get the general idea now it's
just a matter of practice you take what
you're learning right now and you just
got to just do it over and over again
until you start really feeling it i'm
actually really impressed with how fast
jake's picking it up too he just got his
one wheel over the weekend so now that
we've kind of gone over the skid aspect
of it you want to practice actually
getting the nose of your onewheel up
onto a curb you're not trying to climb
it yet you're just kind of getting
comfortable with that sort of motion
it's a very delicate mechanic here
because you have to actually slide into
the curb pressing your front foot down
to accelerate the wheel up the curb
before you actually make contact because
if your wheel makes contact with the
curb before you've actually started
trying to step up you're just going to
bounce off of it and you're going to go
on to the curb and the wheel's going to
stay on the street
nice good and then once you kind of get
used to that then start trying to
practice the skid stop into the curb
all right you passed
so we're slowly starting to combine
these few elements together the next
step is actually the flick of the foot
and arguably that's the hardest part the
reason for the skid stop is because
you're actually jumping off of that back
foot and so once you're about to
actually hit the curb your front foot
slides into it and as your back foot is
completely weightless on the back part
of the foot pad the board just kind of
climbs up it's like you're trying to
stab the sidewalk with your toes that's
what will keep the one wheel going
forward all right guys now's the time i
want to see your full effort i want to
see you get up onto this
[Music]
curb you're being too aggressive jake
nico you're not being aggressive enough
so you want the nose to hit the curb
before the tire does yes
jake is surprisingly the closest one so
far and he just got his one wheel
yesterday
in martial arts people who have learned
less actually can learn new skills
faster because somebody who's been in
this case one wheeling for a long time
they've like developed really hard
patterns and for like new people like me
and jake it's just like this is all new
so it's just kind of like the learning
comes a little bit easier we'll project
well i mean
yeah you're just getting way too late
nico it's a very tricky trick
i will be incredibly surprised if anyone
gets this it took me an entire day of
practicing before i finally got it
you definitely you've definitely got it
jake you just gotta practice it now
oh
i recommend trying to start skidding way
sooner
[Music]
it's really hard to overstate how
important it is to really just jump off
your back foot with all your mind and
just stabbing that front foot forward
way sooner than you expect to
didn't pop my nose
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he actually did it do it again ready go
[Music]
the forward motion is really for your
upper body so that you can pop and move
the board forward but you don't actually
want the board to be moving that much
when it contacts the curb you want there
to be just enough pressure so that that
your your body's forward momentum digs
into the nose and then brings up the
behind with it the final rule is do
everything possible you can do to not
fall once your feet are back on the
board that would have taken me way way
longer had it not been for your teaching
sensei
like i want to give you a hug but i
won't i'm legitimately impressed i even
hosted a one-wheel curb clinic with the
los angeles one wheel group here and
like 20 people showed up and not a
single one of them got it this board has
only like maybe like less than 10 miles
on it wise wise professor wren broke it
down in steps that were easy to
understand easy to follow and easy to do
together
now i would recommend having float
plates when you do this jeff mccoster
from the float life actually makes them
we're also distributed on craft and ride
two amazing sights to get all the
onewheel accessories you might possibly
want but i highly recommend picking up a
pair of float plates they'll protect
your board from this kind of damage
first egg first try
so now i'm going to try something a
little different i'm going to dedicate a
different patreon name
to a different curb for every name
glitch cube
alan almanza
no tech canadian spy philip oxford
paris regiopagic
cg lemonade
jordan
matisse batker sunil s
robin chao
dre dwyer thank you to everyone who
supports us on patreon we've also got a
website up and running if you are
interested in that sort of thing but
yeah
hope you continue to stay safe out there
it's a crazy time there's still probably
going to be some people who think we
shouldn't be here at all
and i mean they've kind of got a point
but i do think that we are trying really
hard to mitigate risk we are not
touching each other we're not coming
close to each other we're wearing masks
and staying outside of each other's
bubbles that's the really key thing here
we're not really being dangerous
just be responsible